Molly Hemingway the Federalist joins us
tonight Molly do we know if the FBI was
aware that Bruce ORS wife Nellie worked
at fusion GPS the FBI should have been
that that information should have been
made available to the court and it was
not made available to the court we still
need to know what the FBI knew and when
it knew it to what extent did I mean do
we have a final answer on the question
to what extent the steal dossier allowed
this spying to proceed in the
investigation to continue
we know that the steal dossier was used
to help secure a warrant on - to surveil
that Christopher artist to surveil a
trump campaign associate we have and
that is pretty explosive information
when you think about it when we started
learning about this the idea that this
dossier which was a Hillary Clinton
funded and originated campaign document
the idea that it would have been
weaponized and used by our intelligence
agencies would have was pretty explosive
and now we all have to acknowledge that
was Bruce or seems like the critical
link I mean here's a guy as Kathryn
Harris just reported who was not a
Russia expert whose main role seem to be
facilitating connection between a
federal law enforcement agency and his
wife's firm but the court never learned
that why is that not rotten why is it
not corrupt well and Bruce Ward was not
at the FBI he was not working on this
FBI investigation he was funneling the
information and he was funneling the
information after the FBI had claimed
that they had terminated Christopher
Steele as a source they claimed that
they terminated him and that they would
not use his information because they
realized that he had been leaking to the
media contrary to what his arrangement
was with the FBI but they still managed
to use his information so you be you
know the fiercest Trump opponent
politically and still have grave
concerns as a civil libertarian and an
American about the way this was
conducted couldn't you in fact your
feelings about Trump should have nothing
to do with your feelings so now I
couldn't agree more so where are the
civil libertarians in this it's a very
good question and this is something that
that really is important because if this
can be done against a major presidential
campaign it certainly can be done
against other people it is there are so
many questions that need to be answered
perhaps there really is a good
explanation for why this all went down
but the idea that you can that people
should just be forced to accept that it
was okay without getting answers to
basic questions about why this
investigation started when it really
started when it officially started when
it unofficially started what was used we
do know already something very bad which
is that the Hillary Clinton funded and
created research document was used by
our by the FBI to secure a wider
unbelievable
so there's another piece of a2 that I
want you to respond to so Republican
congressman mark meadows says that the
FBI and DOJ have developed a creative
work around in order to get surveillance
warrants on people they want to target
here's his account of it we know that
some people at the Department of Justice
and FBI actually gave information to the
media then the stories were reported
then they use those reports to justify
further investigations you know that
that's like saying what we're gonna
incriminate one on one hand and and be
the jury on the other it just doesn't
work that way so I should just note it's
it's still murky a lot of this is murky
but the FBI appears to be pushing back
against this storytelling Fox News that
this is actually incorrect and this is
not the way they went about getting
warrants what's your view of this we're
getting different reports about what
exactly was said we do know though we
know this from the Inspector General
report that came out about the Hillary
Clinton email investigation that there's
an epidemic of leaking at the FBI this
is something that was so severe that the
IG actually spun it off into a separate
investigation because it is so bad that
people with security clearances are
having dozens of contacts with reporters
it's also something that anyone with the
pulse can figure out if they were paying
attention for the last two years that
there were so many leaks of classified
information whether it was about the
dossier whether it was about the
briefing of the dossier to the President
or about other matters such as Mike
Flynn's conversations these were all
leaked to the media and so we do know
that we have a very serious problem when
you're doing a leak you're doing it for
a purpose I think we need to know more
about what the purpose is behind all
these leaks we also know that in that
what we from what we do know of the FISA
application that media reports were used
in that FISA application media reports
that were sourced to the creator of the
Russia dossier himself we we should have
a very high standard for what we take to
a FISA Court
and how we use news reporter you'd think
any sensible judge would laugh at an
application that contained a report from
BuzzFeed news or Yahoo or any news
organization I'm is the FBI it's a DOJ
they should have their own they also
write their also mentioned in the
application an opinion story from the
Washington Post which might not meet the
standard that you would hope for in an
application the closer you get the less
impressive it is Molly thank you very
much